[Musique]
m
c'est la loi de la rue on va régler
cette affaire nous mêmes
j'aimerais voir shaft qu'il demande
john charles junior junior wii vient
parler business
j'aurai besoin que tu m'aides je savais
que ce jour arriverait
c'est quoi la faire je crois que mon
meilleur ami se fait tuer pourquoi un
glossaire au nom non merci je suis
entièrement les barbus qu'est ce que tu
as fait de leur flag
oh je les ai jetés par la fenêtre ça se
fête pas de jeter des flingues par la
fenêtre car les enfants qui vivent aussi
si tu veux poursuivre cette enquête j'ai
devoir jouer les baby sitter avec toi
qu'est ce que tu fous j'ai donc tu vois
pas pas quoi granby je crois que je vais
vous laisser vous amuser sans moi aussi
te plaît dis moi tu l'as pas entraîner
dans des magouilles c'est la mère de
juniors vous en faites pas pour sam
adams définissent mademoiselle chlamydia
ravi de vous rencontrer
tu peux pas frapper aux femmes
pourquoi se serait mise en chine de
faire ça c'est toi qui tu as misogyne en
disant ça j'ai pas parlé de sexe et je
fais pas de distinction quant à bath
merde
c'est quoi tu nous appelles la capoeira
ses brésiliens ça c'est sacré j'étais à
sa d'être fiers de toi
[Musique]
canedo